good evening everybody and welcome on
this rather wet and windy evening so
thank you all for coming um not received
any apologies which is most unusual um
this is the first meeting um following
the festive break so happy New Year to
anybody who have not spoken to already
um are there any Declarations of
interest in the agenda at all no thank
you um we have a copy of the minutes
from the previous meeting oh sorry Ken
all right okay thank you um is everybody
happy with the minutes of the previous
meeting yes thank
you
um so just yeah we do have um three
questions from members of the public
this evening so the first one um is um
with the number of children from the
local area attending erston grammar
diminishing over the last decade
resulting in now almost 2third of erston
grammar school pupils coming from
outside the local area what is there
being done around access to Herston
grammar for children from West Trafford
and I understand there has been a
written response I'll pick that up if
that's if that's okay chair okay I mean
do you want do you want it to just go as
a written response rather than sharing
with the committee I'm happy either way
um yeah you can feel free to share with
the committee and then we'll uh send the
WR response okay no problem um erston
grammar obviously is an academy uh and
therefore independent of Trafford local
Authority um so therefore they operate
according to the funding agreement with
the secary of State um and obviously the
the individual Academy trust uh there's
no mechanism for an acad for an Academy
to return to local Authority control um
an admissions Authority is the body
responsible setting the school's
admission Arrangements I.E how it will
allocate places um and obviously for
aspects of administering this process
applicants wishing to be considered for
admission to a grammar school in
Trafford must first be successful in the
entrance exam for the preferred grammar
school and any decisions regarding these
Arrangements it's solely with the school
not the local
Authority thanks Karen um the next
question is rather long um so um and
it's
in four paragraphs um
so um I don't know if you want to take
these one at a time
or the end at the end okay so the
ofstead 2023 area send inspection of
Trafford local area partnership says and
a quote there is an absence of a
partnership approach to address
semh which um is social emot and mental
health and neurodiversity needs across
Trafford this has resulted in
variability in practitioners
understanding of the additional needs of
these children and young people for some
children and young people this is
impacting negatively on the timely
identification of need and ongoing
support as semh children and young
people often struggle to attend school
due to unmet needs and develop anxiety
and mental health issues due to school
pressures it follows that school absence
is a key indicator of unmet needs and
therefore tracking absence is correct
correctly is vital to timely
identification and ongoing support some
schools within the burough are coding
mental health absences as
unauthorized despite government guidance
stating that absences for illness both
physical and mental health related must
be authorized with code one
illness oh sorry code I illness not
medical or dental appointment unless
there is and quote again genuine and
Reasonable Doubt about the authenticity
of the illness given this what actions
are the council taking to ensure that
traffic schools are coding absences
appropriately to ensure semh children
are identified and supported as early as
possible and ensure that parents are not
subject to fines or prosecution for
their semh child's non-attendance will
the council take steps to ensure that
schools in Trafford recognize that
parents have the necessary authority to
decide whether their child is too unwell
to attend school and that mental health
is a valid reason for
non-attendance schools should not be
insisting on medical evidence when GPS
have been specifically asked not to
provide this for children young people
and cams only has the resources to
accept referrals for the most severe
cases parents are often left in no man's
land unable to access help and
support okay I'll try and there there is
quite a lengthy response which I've sent
over to Harry um but I can try and
summarize very very briefly just the
high level response um obviously we have
a pupil absence team in Trafford quite a
small team and it provides advice to
schools in accordance obviously with the
DFE responsibilities around um working
together to improve attendance and that
also links in with the mental health
issue that might be affecting attendance
um and we've clearly stated to schools
that school staff must record absences
as the um questioner uh shared as
authorized um because of illness and
we've been really clear that that is the
case it should be um recorded as as uh
authorized we also have our Trafford
emotionally based School attendance
guidance and again that makes it quite
clear that again the absence should be
authorized if the school is satisfied
the reason given a genuine um and is
coded I then in line with with illness
and in line with the DFE guidance we
have set a Trafford model attendance
policy at the request of head teachers
in Trafford which we have shared with
our schools and again that is really
clear about um the accurate recording um
of absence related to illness including
mental health um for information um
there was a committee and education
committee report in September of last
year that was recommending that the DFE
should introduce a mental health absence
code uh and set clear thresholds for its
use um that obviously eliminates that
need to provide constant medical
evidence around the absence no time
frame has been given by DFE yet for
implementation just want to reiterate
that penalty notices and prosecutions is
only ever considered as the last resort
in all cases of irregular attendance and
only when the school has exhausted all
strategies uh supportive strategies in
accordance with the working together
agenda so again I think we've got the
model attendance policy that we are and
that we're using to ensure schools um
recognize parents do have the authority
to decide whether their child is too
unwell to attend school it is at the
school's discretion though um in terms
of whether they do authorize the absence
um and but we do work closely with
schools to ensure that they are acting
um according to the guidance so there is
a much more detailed response but again
Harry has got that and more than happy
for that to be shared thank you Karen um
now we do have a further question which
was actually received late um so I just
wanted to make the committee aware that
um despite being asked tonight the
officers may not have had um chance to
um formulate a response so the next
question is as Trafford Council cannot
enforce aligned holidays and erston does
not have any non-selective secondary
schools many families are forced to have
siblings in separate secondary schools
with different holidays this impacts on
their ability to spend time together and
ultimately means that non-catholic
families with children of different
genders are discriminated against can
the council consider providing a fully
non-selective secondary School in
Herston to both avoid discrimination
faced by non-catholic families forced to
separate siblings and improve provision
for lgbtq plus pupils who may not thrive
in a single sex
setting could a non-selective school be
provided through either removing the
selective status of erston grammar
school given that only 10% of local
children are admitted there currently
or converting one or both of the Single
Sex schools to
co-educational if so would either change
need to be Council or parent driven and
how can this be
effective if the latter is the
case Okay in in summary um all of the
secondary schools in Herston are emies
so I refer back to my original point
that the local Authority does not have
any mechanism for an Academy to return
under local Authority control um so you
know there's nothing we can do in terms
of that uh and the selective status
obviously of irstone grammar school
cannot be removed by the local Authority
um again it's the Department's National
and regional directors uh their teams as
well as the education and skills funding
agency those are the ones that provide
that oversight um of the running ofies
in terms of setting up new schools I
think we've been really clear in the
past there is uh there's only uh one one
route that the local Authority has to
set up a school um and that obviously
has to be based on uh sufficiency
pressures of which we don't have any
there's insufficient demand in ernston
to establish a new school in the
locality therefore an application will
be
unsuccessful thanks very much Karen
um I'm not going to ask for questions at
the moment but if if Karen you could
share full response with the committee
um there may be questions arise excuse
me thank you um before we go on to the
next agenda item could I just ask that
we I can see some new faces in the room
as well as some Elder ones um we just
introduce ourselves if we go around so
my name is Denise Weston I'm a broad
Heath Ward counselor and I chair
currently chair this
committee yeah hi um my name is
councelor Rob Duncan I'm the councelor
for Mana Ward and I'm the vice chair of
this committee thank
you hi I'm councelor rupali Paul for Man
Award and I'm the shadow executive for
children and young
people hi my name is Janine day and I'm
the operations director at early break
and part of the achieve all AG substance
missuse service for
Trafford hi everyone my name is am
hodkinson I'm the public health
commissioning manager that cover drugs
and alcohol so I'm here to talk about
the agender item about substance issues
for children young people um and in a
previous life as also a Young Person's
drug and alcohol worker in traed thank
you hi I'm Kate Chesswood I'm a public
health consultant in the public health
Team hi I'm Sarah Butters I work in
education head of Education places
access and vulnerable
children hi everyone Karen samples
Director of
Education hello my name is shaa gallaga
and working in Trafford as a send
Improvement
lead hi I'm Sally Smith lead for sended
inclusion hello I'm councelor Karina
Carter and I am the executive member for
children young
people Council Dillan but for Hail bars
tily South Ward I'm ex official member
as a chair of the health scrutiny
committee
um I'm Emma Hurst counselor for Old
Trafford
Ward hi councelor Joan Bennett counselor
for sale Mo
Ward okay councelor Eve Parker councelor
for sale
Central councelor Zack Deacon sales
central hi I'm Owen Sutton councelor F
ward council sha and is simply
Central councel Shirley Pro to Lo do and
Barton Ward I'm councelor Sarah ho and
I'm Longford
Ward Harry Callahan Democratic Services
officer thank you everybody um can we
move on to um item four which is the
substance and alcohol support for um
young people we have had copies in
advance of the report so if you just
want to bring out some highlights that
would be super thank
you thank you yeah we'll try to keep
keep it relatively brief um um really
just opening up and I'll hand over to my
colleagues um who've been involved in
the detail so the the report obviously
um gives you um a bit of an overview of
some of the Strategic um developments
that and sort of leadership that's going
on around substance use and and alcohol
use in Trafford including for young
people um and some of the detail from uh
our kind of lead provider which uh
obviously who are represented tonight by
Janine
um so a bit more detail around them and
also refers to some of the wider
programs of work that we've got to um
work with other partners to to kind of
embed understanding and learning and and
um Improvement and responses for
children and young people on this
important um issue um so the the um
little bit context there from the case
you're not aware the uh National Drug
strategy which um responded to D Co
black r view um and did lead to some
additional investment that came to local
areas and very welcome of course uh in
the last couple of years um uh there's
some detail there on on that um and the
um aims uh covered there obviously
include working uh to improve the
outcomes for young CH for young people
um it's been quite a focus on increasing
numbers in treatment uh through that but
obviously really important when we're
doing that um particularly young people
that were also looking at the prevention
and the earlier intervention um before
children and people need need treatment
and also making sure that that treatment
is effective and Etc so Janine will
cover a little bit of that I won't go
into the service Janine can give you a
flavor on that um but the other thing um
to just uh highlight is that the um
there is a new uh Trafford alcohol
substance misuse and gambling
partnership um which I chair and um
brings together Partners um from Cross
Trafford uh to kind of Drive some focus
on um those issues and uh that reports
to the health and wellbeing board and
the um safer traffic partnership uh
relatively new so we're really forming
those relationships and increasing the
awareness of what the um offer is out
there but we've also got a very nearly
finalized action plan um to try to um
deliver some some progress and some
improvements in join up particularly so
I think I'll leave it there if that's
okay
hand over to Janine thanks K hi thank
you everyone um so you have the report
already so I'm I'm I'll pull out some of
the highlights but I think one of the
things I really want to talk about
tonight is our work around prevention
which maybe can strengthen this report a
little bit more so in early break we're
not we're not just there to deliver
Treatment Services we're passionate
about preventing young people's
substance use and we do work in a trauma
responsive way and we do work in an
intergenerational um aspect to all our
work um some of our our our prevention
work is around our family work and
that's um working with a structured
program that's evidence-based for our
families and our children and that works
with children from the age of five
upwards um obviously integrated very
much across our partner agenes across
Health and Social care and the voluntary
sector our other work also works with
parent not only children affected by
parental substance use but also
criminality and imprisonment and very
much we have therapists um around that
offer as well and really working hard
with our colleagues in terms of helping
and supporting children and young people
around their emotional and mental health
on their lived
experience um so we we like I said
before we're very passionate about about
working with children and young people
and early break Church has a Northwest
group that looks at new and emerging
substances um for young people and their
risk-taking behaviors that group's made
up of academics um from across the
Northwest but more locally regionally we
have a fantastic um contribution from
Trafford um and definitely across the
rest of the GM um
Network um the information we undertake
surveys every year surveying young
people and we collect evidence-based
information from services and
professionals out in the field that
information helps us to collate the
information and then look at what our
interventions and what education needs
to be pushed out not only to young
people but as opposed to the children's
Workforce what education training do
they need so we try and take a whole
system approach really when looking at
prevention so just kind of um briefly
going specifically now more um on on the
um
on the on the referrals and the data as
you can see in 2022 23 um we went
through some significant changes um in
in the Trafford office and that's um you
can see that that's reflected in our
performance I'd like to reassure um
counselors and partners here tonight
that actually we've definitely returned
that curve and we're actually Pro
performing better than we was in um
201920 so um or we're on track to
perform better than then so um currently
we've had um 168 referals and we've seen
273 young people in the year so
hopefully that offers some
reassurance um as you can see they're
just moving quickly on um in our
referral sources um we have a really
good um respectful and strong
relationships with our partners um in in
Trafford and we're High support High
challenge to each other um so if things
aren't working right we do have those
respectful relationships where we can
pick up the phone um or if we're
noticing a gap in Services um so I think
the data um kind of stands for it speaks
for itself there some of the um I
suppose things around health is is an
identified issue for us and we have
picked up some of the blockages around
our a& which were in a process at the
minute um working with our colleagues um
in a& but also and then referral
Pathways as well um the other um area I
suppose is Stand Out is why if we had
such a increase in our youth Justice
service um so again it's not that
offending gone up or anything like that
but we've actually got a worker sat with
that service and got a real good strong
link and we're actually focusing not
only on them young people in youth
justice but on the preventative aspects
around youth justice as well so our PI
service and some of those wider offers
we work very closely with um with our to
colleagues in talk shop and we actually
provide reception Service as part of
that offer we reach our um D work with
our more diverse um groups as well um
from that base um over the last couple
of years um or last year um early break
achieved a quality standard in the
rainbow flag as well making us an
accessible service for those young
people in our lgtbq
communities um we don't Bas we don't
wait for young people to come to us at T
shop we're active and we're out there we
we do outreaching in our communities and
we do go into our ban communities um and
up into Partington and wherever we might
feel that there's a hotspot area then we
will go there we deliver Outreach um
with our colleagues as well in in uh in
Youth
Services strengthening Partnerships this
year some of our works focused on
complex
safeguarding um so again we're lincing a
worker within that team and attending
some of those meetings the children that
missing from home we've reviewed our
Pathways in terms of our cared for
children as well so again um those the
care for children now have a direct um
named Link Worker um within those within
those services and and within some of
the children's homes we also attend the
Virtual School um
meeting
um we have
um so just kind of I suppose moving
through I don't want to kind of take too
much time so just moving through you can
see that the um the substance Ed
primarily for Trafford is cannabis
primarily alcohol and cocaine um and
fourthly katamine this is not too
dissimilar to any of our other areas
Cain is the new and EM is the the
emerging substance which young people
tend to be using at an earlier age so
we've actually got a Northwest group at
the minute coming together with
academics and with experts within the
field to look at interventions and
review the treatment protocols that we
have in place and that will feed up to
the National
acmd um The Advisory Council of um
substance shoes I my shoes um our
outcomes as you can see um our total
number in treatment so there are more um
entrenched young people quite often
those with a number of Aces um living
with quite complex lived experiences
some of them um and again you can see
there um a much lower number thankfully
um that that is a is kind of quite a
good good response um and again kind of
data although it looks low because it's
2223 is reassuring again for this year
and our outcomes um so our planned
outcomes and you can see there our
planned exits um currently this year
we're um 96% on um planned exits
successful exits compared to our
national average of um 80% so again
we're
succeeding hand over to Amy now to
finish
off thanks Janine um I'm just G to talk
about the um New emerging substances so
that we're seeing in traffic so Janine's
kind of explain the Northwest group and
what's kind of done to monitor changes
around um GM and some of the kind of
questionnaires we do to get that Insight
um one of the ones um which we are
seeing is around youth vaping um which
I'm sure is no surprises a lot around
that nationally is there in the media um
so just to explain a bit of the work
going on locally around youth Vape in
Trafford so we've um commissioned some
work with early break who are going to
work in partnership with our school
health colleague
um they're delivering some targeted work
in for this year so that includes um Dro
in at every Secondary School um to give
young people the opportunity to talk to
a professional around um vaping e
cigarettes and kind of understanding
some of the Miss misconceptions around
those the differences between kind of
regulated and unregulated and kind of
understanding some of the harms um we're
also looking at some webinars with
parents um when speaking with our
education colleague we um the feedback
was that they'd kind of try and um how
do word this kind
of putting
some you know barriers around um not
vaping in schools and things like that
but kind of I'm kind of paraphrasing
here the feedback from parents was well
well it's better than smoking and kind
of helping them to understand um the
risk with these unregulated Vapes in
particular um so we're doing some work
with parents um we've got three webinars
one in January February March um we're
also doing some um webinars for
professionals um which councilors are
welcome to attend and that's open to any
kind of professional in Trafford um and
we also have a pathway around use vaping
um so that if a young person is using
nonregulated Vape um or they using
vaping alongside other substances they
can get support from um early Break um
or they can get support from school
health as well um Trafford have also
been successful um with our population
Health Fellowship so this is a program
that's funded by NHS England um we're
one of four in the Northwest and we're
the only one um focusing on um youth
Vapin so it's basically where we have a
12- month research project um we're
focusing that on youth vaping as I say
and the successful candidate candidate
has been a school nursing Trafford um
one of our school nurses so she's going
to do some research in youth vaping with
children kind of understanding their
perceptions of it um why they're doing
it um do their families use it as well
what if they wanted to stop doing it
what would what would help them is it
something on their own is it groups and
also looking at parents as well there's
been a bit of a gap in the research in
terms of looking at that parental
perspective um to their perceptions of
whether they Vape as well um so that's
some of the work that's going on around
um vaping the emerging substance is um
ketamin which um jimine has already
mentioned um there's some concern
although the numbers are low there's
concern around the physical impacts
that's having on traffic J people so
we're doing some work with our physical
health colleagues and we're going to
some of the meetings and wider networks
with them to
um better get the awareness around
asking the question around substance use
so it's been um picked up rather than
getting missed um with other physical
health
difficulties um and then in terms of
future development so we're in the
process of developing our um needs
assessment for drugs and alcohol hoping
to fin finalize that in March um which
is I'm really excited about it I think
it's a really good piece of work to know
what the unmet needs are for Trafford
and kind of where we need to drive our
plans and our commissioning decisions in
the future um so that's something that
we're working on at the moment and we're
also working more closely with the um
traffic strategic safeguarding
partnership in terms of sharing the data
that we get um from our achieve service
um to that safeguarding board so they
are aware of how many people in
treatment are families or if young
people under 18 that may be affected by
um parental substance use um so that's
basically anshell I think thank you very
much ladies um do any um members have
any comments or questions on the
report uh councilor
Paul hi uh thank you for the report as
so do you Le with the GMP as well to
stop the drugs and alcohol from reaching
young persons because to get rid of the
use of substance misus it is important
that it does not reach in the hands of
the young people so that's like initial
state so yeah
thanks I'll answer that yeah um so yes
we do we actually um have started
getting referrals from GMP uh for young
people that they're coming into contact
with as part of their early intervention
prevention um aspects we also um we also
have a training resource that's been
developed over probably that twoyear
period by young people and it's called
stress out brain and the training is um
we work with young people to ask them um
what messages would have been helpful
for the for professionals to have with
them um at a younger age um and so we
they've developed some really creative
resources and some conversational tools
one of them's an animation and on that
we deliver half day training we've
delivered also to our colleagues in
complex Safeguard in across grayon
Manchester and also um our Trafford
Service as well and I I can invite
anyone if you want to go on the stressed
out brain training it's on the Safeguard
in Board website you're all welcome all
right thank you useful um councelor
Bennett oh hi oh
sorry sorry Amy sorry I was just going
to add that JP are also um represented
in the Trafford alcohol substance misuse
and gambling partnership um so we always
have um the I mean they've come every
time haven't they and we always have an
item around kind of intelligence so if
there's anything they're aware of and
it's something we can pick up in the
service and in terms of Outreach and
vice
versa thank
you
then recogize young children who have
got a gambling problem I mean if you're
taking drugs or alcohol there's usually
an
external identifier for that but how do
you get hold of children who are
[Music]
gambling from our operational view it's
difficult but what we do a preventative
measure is we look at those young people
that are heavily involved in gaming
because quite often gaming can be one of
the early identifiers so very much so we
we work with the
workforce as well so and it's very much
relation trying to develop our
partnership sorry I'll just add a little
bit to that thank you for the question
and I think um last time I was here we
talked a bit about gambling as a follow
up to a paper on um inequalities and I
have got a um short briefing that is
ready to um to share with um colleague
councelor who asked last time but I can
I can share it with um more of you to
give a bit more detail about what's
available um you're right to pick up
that the partnership uh that's on drugs
and alcohol is also also covers gambling
because of some of those um as you say
those kind of addiction issues but the
the understanding the knowledge and the
support services are much more limited
than than we where we are with drugs and
alcohol um there is some good um
training that's um been kind of
developed by um people who have
experienced uh with lived experience of
gambling and recovery and uh distinct
from the industry which is also quite
hard to find a lot of Industry
involvement in in gambling of course so
that chapter one training which has been
commissioned by and funded by greater
Manchester actually gmca colleagues but
but but supported by us locally in terms
of targeting so we've had a round of
those made available um we're waiting
for the next round to be made available
and promote those as wide as possible to
colleagues um but it is a it's been a
really really um informed informative
discussions that we've had at the
partnership about gambling the two times
that we've had agenda items there um and
raising awareness and and and seeing
Partners start to understand what why it
might be an issue for them why they
might need to ask about it and it's an
item on our agend action plan now to to
ask and to look for the you know to have
that conversation as a routine same
issue we've got actually for a lot of
the drug and alcohol uh needs assessment
that we've been doing is is hard to get
data and information because people
don't ask for it and sometimes they
don't notice it as you say so yeah it is
it is on our R but I think a bit behind
in terms of where we are with drugs and
alcohol but yeah thank you for the
question thank you counselor Enis thank
you chair thank you uh for the very much
for the report it's really comprehensive
and and informative just looking at page
six table ble to um obviously you've
talked about the the three top
substances but that um figure for
cocaine use since 2019 2020 is obviously
just just more than doubled what what
are the causes behind that why why young
people accessing and turning towards
that I think where we're seeing we' seen
um the increasing cocaine use emerge um
I suppose during lockdown um when
dealers very clearly started marketing
their cocaine at not grams or half grams
but much lower quantities so it became
more available for young people um and I
think it's just grown in population
obviously um you look at marketing and
media and quite often it's portrayed as
a drug of wealth or success so it's it's
not one thing I think it's it's a it's a
collaborative thing and it's generally
young people that are moving towards
older adolescence if they are younger
and it's more of than complex young
people that may be associating with
older PE um so yeah that's thank you
thank you can I just ask a question do
do you um split these figures at all
between um north and south of of the B
I'm just wondering if cocaine was
perhaps more popular if that's the word
in the wealthier areas and cannabis
maybe in more deprived areas yeah no I
mean working with the team because we
look at you know is there any patterns
across our geographical areas and
unfortunately it's not cocaine use is
across across all patches it's not just
our wealthier areas um it certainly is
certainly some of our deprived areas um
and also in some of our Bame areas as
well so it kind of goes
across unfortunately so do we find
obviously this all links in as well to
do we find that it could lead to an
increasing crime because they need to
get the money to buy these things it's
more exploitation criminal
exploitation um
unfortunately I'll just add a little bit
on that sorry just um there's a violence
um needs assessment that's just been um
done as you may be aware it's a part of
the for to submit it to to the home
office so all areas have done that um
and it's uh you know part of taking a
public health approach to to violence
reduction um so that's given us some
some new insights to into the um Trends
in terms of violence which one of the
find major findings is that uh most
violence is not uh perpetrated uh by
young people um but by um adults and so
younger middleaged adults so that's a
reminder to but it does highlight some
of the links with um drugs offenses
again relying on on some data sources
that are difficult to interpret
including police data for some of this
but we triy to triangulate it where
possible so um that does that does give
us some additional information for our
needs assessment thinking about what the
drivers might be and some of those
things about the market changes that um
Council Paul has also question so that's
been a useful exercise alongside
actually thank you councelor jump into
have a question yeah thank you um
councelor um Weston
um just a couple of questions really um
and I'll also draw to page six as well
because it's quite
concerning um with regards to the um
drug increase um our partners actually
working with head teachers direct to
address
this and in turn our partners working
with families I am assuming to help
tackle that as well um
that's relating to the drug misuse and
I'm just wondering whether that's linked
to the increase in vaping as well since
2019 thank
you yes thank you
m so yes certainly is linked with um
vaping obviously vaping has exploded
across young people's um substance use
across the country not only in Trafford
um unfortunately and so yes the increas
in vaping um obviously we know that
young people are also accessing THC so
cannabinoid um Vapes as well um which is
is is also causing so some um concerns
um but we do Link in very much with our
um with our colleagues in education our
Ed teachers and our safeguarding leads
um within each School each worker has
named schools um and the contacts the
designating safeguarding lead on a
regular basis
and ask if they um have have any support
needs or any issues whether we've got
identified concerns with groups of young
people then um or emerging patterns
happening then we will go in and do a
targeted piece of work quite often that
might look like targeted Outreach um and
then identified sessions with some of
those young people in all our work we
support families so we never just work
with the child in isolation we get
signed consent to work with the parents
or the carers for that child um and it
always encompasses um a family
offer I think just to add in terms of um
families as well in the process of
developing a hidden harm audit which
will is being developed for um drug
Services social care um and the hope of
the roll out to wider Services really to
check that services are asking the
questions around the whole family and
the impact on um hidden harm um around
children so that's in development in the
hope that that will pick some of that up
so the services that we commission
can no thank you very much um that's
great thank you very much um one last
question briefly you mentioned webinars
before
um could that not be done face to face
instead of through a webinar because I'm
a great believer in face to face please
thank
you I'm a great believer in face to face
too but unfortunately parents have very
busy lives and as much as we would love
to see them face to face all our
stressed out brain training is face to
face everything we offer is face to face
but for our parents they requested um a
webinar
so thank you Council so thanks
chair the thing that concerns me the
most is the right in Kine use um I go to
lots of festivals and I see the results
of ketamin OES and it's frankly
frightening and the thought that are
young PE and that's with adults the
thought that our young people are
accessing it more as a drug of choice
really concerns
me what do we
do so this is some of the work that
we've been I've been leading on um
regionally and we're looking at because
we are seeing younger uh younger
adolescents experimenting at a younger
age now it has is coming down it always
used to be the older adolescence so
we're we're looking at what the evidence
is what the harms are um and what
information we put out there obviously
it's got to be credible and factual for
young people otherwise we'll be exposed
and they won't ever believe a word that
we say again so um we are working with
academics with Specialists with
Consultants with education actually s s
I think sale grammas in that in that
group as well helping us to say what
information do we give to professionals
what education and awareness training do
they need but what are the messages um
to children and young
people thank you councelor
Parker thank you um I just wanted to ask
if any work or is any work being done in
terms of
prevention um to stop The Vaping shops
appearing on our high streets because it
seems really obvious they're so next
that seem to be popping up next to high
schools in particular
so so we um do pay towards um a trading
standards post um which fls aart that so
they specifically work on the kind of
smoking vaping um area for us um alcohol
as well um so that will form part of
their work um some of the stuff that
we're also doing as well as in part of
the webinars is trying to build up that
intelligence so they know where to
Target and where to go so as part of the
webinars making it really clear how
parents professionals um Can report such
incidences um so they can action some of
that but we do have a dedicated resource
within Public Health funding to cover
that just add a little bit um I think
it's maybe referenced in here but you
might have not noted the the um
government consultation on increasing
regulation for um VAP vaping and
ecigarettes as well and we've put in a
um a strong uh response to that as have
obviously many of our colleagues um
around um the country um but the hope is
that that will introduce at least some
of the um restrictions on the marketing
and the colors and the flavors and the
the things that appeal to Y to young
people um at the moment we're very
limited in our powers um for those um
premises and and you're right they're
filling a kind of Gap in the in the High
Street in some cases so yeah it is um
something that our um colleagues in
trading standards and Regulatory
services are really on board with with
us about which is really good um we
recognize that the harms but yeah bit
bit limited than you I think that's the
difference really isn't it with the
Vapes they are so readly available and
they are targeted at young people with
the colors and you know and I I don't
know what what they cost um whereas
cigarettes have to be behind closed
doors now and the very very expensive I
mean you've only got to get on a tra and
you can smell that sweet smell um and a
lot of the young people are quite open
about it aren't they yeah it's not there
doesn't seem to be any stigma to to to
vaping um that there would be to any of
the other substances including smoking I
think I think the challeng the challenge
we've got a bit is the is the
differentiation between the kind of
illegal Vapes and and the use of Vapes
for with elicit substances as well and
it's therefore very difficult for a
parent or professional somebody on the
tram to know the difference isn't it so
you do have to have that real
understanding and subtlety of the kind
of different offers and messages and so
yeah so that's where the trading
standards activity is focused obviously
at the moment is on the illicit um sales
and obviously underage sales thank you
councelor
Hurst I firstly I just wanted to say say
thank you for the report I I know a
young number of young people who've
accessed the service and have really
appreciated it and found it helpful um I
just wanted to ask in terms of Ages um I
can see that the peak of your young
people are sort of 15 16 17 and I wanted
to know whether you thought it was that
there were less problems amongst the
older adolescents or whe they're
accessing different services or are not
accessing
services
okay so
um yes I
mean it's it's difficult is it it's like
so for us as an organization when we
first started working in traford the
older age range was much higher one of
our Ambitions was to intervene at an
earlier stage I think with young people
once they um once they get through the
the older or get to the older
adolescence by that time we hope or our
expectation is is actually they're
starting to focus on their education a
bit more or work a bit more and maybe
they um work through some of them
difficulties but we do work with um our
young adults and we do have Pathways
from our young adults services to try
and make us an accessible service across
all the uh age ranges as well and just
following on from that with the young
people that you're working with that
sort of approach 21 do you have a smooth
transition to Adult Services or do you
keep hold of them yeah very much so so
um anyone under up up to the age of 21
it's straight away if they're um
recreational drug users come in
problematic and don't require treatment
they will certainly sit with us within a
a Young Person's offer again young
people that have been cared for or maybe
have scnd um needs or learning needs
then they will certainly stay within our
service and that's up to the age of
25 thank you that's really
helpful thank you very much I don't
think there are any more questions so
thank you so much for the report it's
been really useful I've learned a lot
about Brooks that I didn't know I have
to say um and I don't think we've
actually invited you before but I'm I'm
sure we'd like to see you again with any
updates in the future if that's okay
you're more than welcome to stay for the
rest of the meeting but if youve
somewhere better to go like
home please do feel free to leave
us okay so can we move on to the next
item which is the send inspection report
um I don't know who's presenting oh it's
sh yes I've been kindly nominated in
Jill's absence at the very last minute
by my colleagues by
vote so um what you've got in front of
you I'll be really brief um is the
highlights of the inspection um that
took place on the um in October was very
long time was not that long and the
report um was published on the 22nd of
December ni Christmas present for
everyone um and one of the things just
to highlight really really clearly the
send inspection is an area local
partnership inspection it is not an
inspection of the local Authority it is
an area send inspection and very much
reflecting the the system issues to do
with their cnj needs for children which
is very important and to recognize
obviously the last time Trafford was
inspected within 2017 which was some
time ago and under a completely
different framework this framework has
only been um live since January 2023 um
so it's newer than itself um as you can
see that um the the outcome is that um
there are three possible outcomes and
for Trafford the outcome is that power
Arrangements need to inconsistent
experiences for children said um that
Accords with our own view um as
highlight in the report we have to
produce a very comprehensive self
assessment as part of the inspection
process that was 48 pages long it's
quite long was very much a partnership
document also done with parent care um
Forum um and one of the pleasing things
about the inspection activity was um
that the CQC and of said fed back to us
that you know yourselves quite well and
and that our own findings our own
evaluation accorded with with what they
found children people which I think is
really important um in terms of what
happens next um we we have to um publish
a strategic Improvement plan and we have
to publish that by the 14th of February
in um and we also have to have a meeting
with the um DFA which is part of their
require and monitoring arrangements and
that also happens to be on the 4 4
February um the report one of the things
that that we that we just wanted to kind
of highlight really clearly the report
is five pages long it's not a lengthy
document um but there was a huge
richness of feedback that we got through
the inspection process in terms of daily
meetings with the inspectors um and one
of the things that we've tried to do is
capitalize on that and really understand
that and use that um across the
partnership um because the report within
itself is not is not a lengthy document
and was never going to be um and so the
richness of that wider learning is
something that we didn't we didn't
particularly want to want to lose um we
know um that um the the inspection um
was really clear that we've got a lot of
passionate people in Trafford working
really hard with children young people
who know children young people really
really well who are passionate and
ambitious for what they want to do um
children young people would send um but
as we as the self assessment reflected
we know that that translation into that
strategic intent that we have and what
that looks like can practice on the
ground operationally for Children and
Families is too andc consistent um and
that across the areas in the ambition
plan of which there are six um our own
reflection and was fed back to us is
that there is inconsistency in terms of
some of those strands of work and some
of them are not as advanced as others um
we know that and there has been a lot of
good work in terms of Parental um
engagement um and the leaps process
which is um the the lived and experience
you experienced advisory panels very
very complicated to say and there were
there were some really good examples
that's something that the for the parent
C forum and have instigated and involves
professionals and that was reflected
very strongly but what we know is that
children's voice and Trafford is not as
strong as it needs to be and that
reflected factors in the assessment that
the voice of children in people is an
area where we we need to strength we
need to
strengthen we know um I think it's
reflected in the question about um semh
um and um that that was always obviously
an area in which we need a better
systems response and particularly
respond to the needs of neurodiversity
in terms of children young people and we
know that intra nationally we've seen a
huge growth in that area um and that's
something um that inspectors felt that
were individual examples within our
schools for example of some really good
practice in that space But that it was
inconsistent um we've been doing quite a
lot of work since I got here on um the
quality of educational healthcare plans
and um we we felt that there is some
sign of improvement and they were
particularly positive about our
education and psychology service and our
Sena service um but we know that there
is too much variability in that area and
and that we we need to improve that um
similarly that we need to strengthen our
annual review process as well um and
particularly alignment of meetings for
children who are experiencing multiple
services and therefore families are
going to multiple meetings often about
the same thing um so there is a there
was a skill in aligning some of that of
that work um we knew that ourselves um
and that was fed back to us in terms of
inspection um preparation for adult
children transitions has been a human
traffic for a long time it's one of the
first things the parent care re Forum
said to me when I first came here um and
and the inspection highlighted that
particularly in terms of preparation for
agile Tor we um we need to accelerate
our work in that area um that we um we
know that it's an issue but we were fed
it was fed back to us that we need to
pick up the pace and and there's a lot
of work that we need to do in that
space um so so in terms of and I like to
ask L of questions I'm going to leave
lots of time for that um so in terms of
what we need to do next we've got an
Ambitions plan and we need to co-produce
our response to the inspection which is
why you haven't got one in front of you
because we need to do that as a
partnership um we have not got a lot of
time um as I said we've got it's got to
be in the public domain by the 14th of
February um so we will be be fast
tracking some some of that information
it will um respond to the four areas so
there are four recommendations in the
report but it would all it will also to
address the areas of improvement that
were highlighted underneath that so it
will not be the full Ambitions plan um
because that would be exceedingly
lengthy and very difficult to keep up to
date but it will be more than the four
areas that have been identified in terms
of some of that detail and it will be a
public fac and document it will be
really important that it has um a level
of um transparency that parents and
carers can understand and pick up what
that what that means um so um I think
the the ask is to um as I know you will
ask ask any questions that you wanted um
we will um provide regular updates in
terms of the Improvement plans for the
committee as in terms of the frequency
that you that um that you decide um and
um on the um obviously the copy of the
action plan here for for more
discussion thank you sha are there any
questions I'm sure there will
be okay so I'm going to take in order
that I saw your hand um counselor any
first please thank you chair and thank
you for the report there are some things
to welcome just off the bat um really
positive attitudes expressed by send
experienced young people who are also
LGBT about the care and opportunities
they're receiving in traff I think
that's a lovely thing to read and and
something to wel and also as well as
you've said there about um knowing
ourselves and there aren't any major
shocks um it seems to to to officers
about the the outcome of the report
could so into the questions because I've
got loads of
could you elaborate further on each of
the six work streams within this end
Ambitions plan so what particular uh
work streams are sitting behind those
pillars the six pillars that you've
mentioned and how will these Drive
improvements in the services that's
number one um on on Parental engagement
um what efforts beyond the the parent
care forum that we've got are being made
to sort of reach new people are we
always talking to the same send
experienced families are we trying to
reach out side of our bubble or are we
uh being complacent there I'm also aware
from from casework that at these
partnership meetings that LE there's a
send data dashboard which is reviewed at
partnership meetings is that something
which this committee could have site on
in the future I'll pause there um I've
got loads of questions hopefully chair
you'll allow me to come back in in a bit
we're gonna share this out since I was
nominated for the reporting so Karen's
going to start with the with the
Ambitions plan and then I'll pick up the
next one that's okay
yeah in terms of the the Ambitions plan
um we are at a point really where we
need to we as as Shona says we have the
six Ambitions and I think the positive
thing is there's nothing in those
Ambitions that needs to change in order
to satisfy the outcome of the inspection
and improve our activity so I kind of I
think that kind of reflects the fact
that our view of ourselves was accurate
and and certainly I think the inspection
team recognized that the the Ambitions
were the right thing um it is something
that we need to publish we need to make
it a a a public fa and document so it's
really really clear and I think the
other bit is it was co-produced with
families as well um so again it's you
know it's it's a document that's live it
continues to uh to be updated so the six
Ambitions every ambition um has an
ambition lead uh and that's across the
local area so it covers Education Health
and Social care and the ambition leads
um all attend Steering group just in
terms of the governance Arrangements now
to report back on um the the kind of
pace and traction and activity that sits
behind those individual Ambitions there
are kpis in place as well and that links
into the data dashboard and the
scorecard that obviously you referred to
which we will be happy to share um as
part of our updates regular updates so
you can kind of see um impact against
the
kpis um and um within each of the
Ambitions there are work streams that
we'll be delivering on that and I think
you know when they talked about as
showna referenced um when they talked
about kind of that that that difference
between strategic and what was going on
on the ground level what they saw was
some of those Ambitions were more mature
in certain areas and others governance
Arrangements were stronger around
certain Ambitions than others and work
streams were delivering pace and
Traction in a strengthened way so
ambition one is the children's voice
that is one that is the one that's
underdeveloped uh shown is leading on
that as a starter for 10 uh you know
we've obviously got to vanish Shona's
workload um so we are um working on how
how we we roll that out and and shown as
put some detail around that ambition two
is very much around that early
identification the the early years bit
in the best Beginnings board delivers
the op the work around the um ambition
two ambition three the lead is Sally uh
head of send and inclusion and that's
very much around the quality of the
experience for families thinking about
EHC process Etc uh ambition for is um I
think it's PFA testing me now uh and
obious again we what we're going to do
is is uh roll into that some of the
other transition work inspector said we
really need a cohesive transition
strategy so we can see what the pathway
is from early years all the way through
into adulthood but we know the early
years but is actually quite strong the
year to six to year seven is complex for
all of the reasons that we know
transition in Trafford can be um so
there will be some work going on around
that um and really looking at how we
incentivize inclusion in the secondary
sector and build that trust and
confidence in the secondary sector and
then into the PFA PFA side we have a
section around early help family help
and very much the role of of um social
care um within one of our Ambitions and
the final ambition is Health uh and
obviously mft leads are uh working on
that ambition so hopefully what we can
do is as part of the updates we can
bring progress reports around the
Ambitions as well but in terms of tpf
and the The Wider reach into families um
so we know um that in Trafford and there
isn't an equal spread of the Al voice
that we hear um so we know particularly
in terms of the annual parent care
survey and we know in terms of some of
the engagement events that parents in
the north are not as well represented as
parents and other parts of the bough um
so that that's part of the work that
we're we're trying to take forward and
actually I was at one of the schools
today and talking a little bit about um
where the engagement points for families
are a parent care forum has a massive
role to play in send to sh partner but
it will never be the only place that
parents um want to engage with things
and some parents want to engage in
particular topics but not in everything
s related and so we we do have more work
to do to vary what that looks like at at
various levels so individually for
parents involved in their individual
child and what that corporate abused
activity looks like on what I would call
a specified basis so when we're
commissioning something or there's a
particular area of of need thinking
about how parents come together and then
that strategic level which is very much
where the Forum are are the Strategic
partner um so um
we've started the Char Cafe is in in
four of the localities I think it's fair
to say um there's mix take up um I'm
going to one on Thursday um so and I'm
hoping for a good turn now being emailed
by a call of parents asking I'm going to
be there so um we do know that we that
there's more to build on in that in that
area I think that is always really
challenging in send because um sometimes
um people want to share their really
positive experiences and they want to
share their really negative experiences
but they don't always want to share
their kind of you know middle of Road
experiences and so I think that's an
ongoing thing that we we'll need to keep
an eye on we do have a regular
conversation at send partnership board
with the parent career Forum about that
wider reach representation they do open
all their events to all parents and
careers so it's not it's not as if you
have to be in the Forum to take part in
those things and we do see parents at
events that the Forum hold who aren't
active members of The Forum so that that
still does exist but it it's definitely
something that that
um that needs to be ongoingly developed
and we need to think about how we go to
families not ask them to come to us
would be my uh View and just on the data
because that's one of my other big
things um we do have a data
dashboard as you see in the report some
of the our data incend is underdeveloped
um and and there is more to do in making
sure that the richness of the
performance information H exists in some
areas in send we are quite data rich in
other are areas it is underdeveloped um
in terms of the metrics beneath the high
level metrics what that looks like
underneath so there is still a bit more
to do to do that so that we can link the
bits of performance information together
because you can never look at one metric
on its own it doesn't tell you enough um
so that that is is a work in progress
and we have developed the dashboard I
think since I've even been here and and
more plans to develop that and even more
but more than happy for S of that just
to come in on the the data bit because
we're part of the ch partnership program
as well which is obviously linked to the
delivery of the the new Sun reforms the
testing of the new Sun reforms we're
looking that the maybe some funding that
comes from the CPP to actually help us
um actually recruit some form of of data
analyst post specific to send because I
think you know that extra capacity not
just the intelligence with the extra
capacity to provide some of the import
the analysis would be really
helpful um Council
BR thank you
I've also got lots of questions but I'm
I'm only going to ask two now
because no doubt other people have got
the same questions as me I have to take
my glasses off now so that I can
read first
off I think the results better than
um than it could have
been and I've still got some concerns
from several years ago now where we
don't seem to be making much progress um
the the first one listening and acting
on the voice of
children we've not been doing that well
for so long I so I'd like to know what
the plans are please
to to to be able to do that effectively
so that we can we can say hand on heart
this is what our children and young
people think and then um the other one
that I'll ask about for now is about and
your
reviews
um it feels
like they're not
consistent that some reviews seem to
happen well and easily and other reviews
um
don't and so again I'd like to know what
plans there are please to try and um
level that so that we have consistently
good annual reviews and that'll do for
now thank you so I'll take the
children's one and then s's going to
take the annual review question um so I
think in terms of the plans that we've
got um currently doing I'm currently
doing a bit of a map and exercise um
about what currently exists because one
of the things that the inspector said is
you've got some good things but you're
not joining all your dots um so they saw
some really lovely practice for example
in the sensory impairment service in
particular about engagement with
children um and so one of the things was
how do you how do you take what's good
and learn from that and spread that
across we also know there are some
lovely examples in schools of how they
capture children's VI and what and what
they're doing so um at the moment one of
the things that that we're undertaking
is some mapping um the other thing that
that we're exploring is the resource and
attached to this if you want children's
voice strategically in terms of really
driv and practice you have to Resource
that it doesn't it's not going to happen
and bi osmosis and so um again that's
one of the things that I'm exploring
what what could that look like what
could we commission um we've had some
exciting conversations that are not yet
full but but in that in that in very
much that process but also making sure
that the voice of children young people
would send is across ranges of need
because the way voice happens for
children is very different um because
not all children s needs want to or or
able to use their their voice in the way
that you know we we are all able to so
that there are multiple layers in terms
of what that looks like and we also need
to make sure that we've got a Workforce
that is confident and able with space to
engage with children and send in the way
that needs to happen you can't ask
children five minutes before a meeting
what they would like to happen that that
that isn't going to work so we do need
to make sure that we create the capacity
for that that operational engagement on
that very regular basis and that that
the workforce feel empowered to um
listen to parents voice and that's very
important but
actually really listen to what children
have got to say to say as well and that
that sometimes be a little bit of a
challenge because not all of us want
what our parents want and children would
send aren't any different um and and why
would they be or why should they be and
so I think there are some examples where
I have seen some lovely examples of
practice where people know um children
really well what was sometimes not good
at here is Translating that relationship
based into what you can see written down
so practitioners and I've heard them
speak beautifully about children young
people but when I read that plan I can't
say that in the same way which means
someone picking up that piece of paper
can't see that either so there's
definitely some some more to do in terms
of that space it's an area I feel
exceedingly strongly about um it's it's
it's an area where I think nationally
and there is much more to do in terms of
making sure that children would send get
their voices heard first we would never
dream of speaking for a 16-year-old that
didn't have send needs or asking their
parents what they want that shouldn't be
acceptable for children at send in my
view and and so there there there's
there's there's a journey to go on there
but one of the things about Trafford
that's really impressive is people know
children really well here they're
developing that relationship they're
doing that work we need to make sure
we're capturing it and that's the bit
we're not we're not doing well enough
and that's the bit we need to take
forward and I'm gonna leave Sally with
the exciting an your r
view thanks sha um I mean there is some
overlap there as as you can imagine and
making sure that we're getting the own
people's views into their anual views as
well
um and I think you hit the nail on the
head when you said you know we're saying
inconsistency and we agree there's some
really good practice out there and we
need to use that so we have in the past
you know had exemplars from schools at
the Seno Forum sharing that practice and
we regularly offer training on you know
person- centered ways of working but our
monitoring of whether that happens on a
regular basis it comes back to the data
hasn't really been there to follow you
know to kind of complete that Circle of
checking those reviews um the quality
assurance of them going through them to
see how did the review go how many were
person centered how many were attended
by the the the young person how many
were attended by the Health social care
colleagues that that needed to attend so
we've got
um work around uh action planning around
and review sitting in in ambition three
that we mentioned before fits it with
our timeliness action plan so it fits in
with some of that we've got the Tim L
anual reviews the quality of reviews
which fits in with the quality assurance
for framework that we've been started
some auditing that Sean has been leading
on there so that annual reviews are part
of that um mentioned person Center
reviews year 60 the timing just of some
as well say year six reviews we've been
looking at one of our issues as far as
not record not knowing whether reviews
have been done or within our system we
thought they were done but we weren't
necessarily checking that they've been
uploaded correctly onto the system the
senos needed training to make sure
that's happening but also just looking
know whether that time um when we ask
for bulk reviews to be done like in year
six is that actually causing a problem
then when they move into year seven
we're finding that we they're not done
in a timely way because the secondary
schools are still spreading them out or
doing them all in the summer when we've
done them in the Autumn and so
automatically they're all out of date
you know so we're working on that at the
moment to get feedback from the senos
and say what what would work better to
make sure they're done but we've also
got actions in there around that multi-
agency attendance you know make making
sure we get the right information so
it's quite a lot but it's all in the not
all in the Ambitions plan the details of
other action plans below that but it is
moving on as
a thank you um councelor
s um okay yes thank you for the report
um and I than coun plor for basic taking
off FR of my questions um uh and yeah
excellent excellent news that um that
that it was found that you your your own
self self assessment was um was broadly
broadly right
um which um brings me to looking at
section
3.7.1 um about uhh and
neurodiversity uh and the early
identification um and it's would it come
as no surprise to anybody work working
working on the grounds that the there's
this huge issue where the identification
first identifications there is some need
some individual
need the the pro the gulf between those
first conversations between
professionals and actual um uh proper
proper response uh is is is far too in
many cases is far too far too long as in
a matter of years um
so I I I'm asking was this already
realized as something that needed um
further
strengthening um and uh if it was then
what was already being done to further
strengthen it um because uh if we if we
if we do know our our weaknesses already
um what was already so what was already
been done and how can that then be built
on further um to to close this uh very
very problematic area um the second
question regarding joining was regarding
joining the dots was um regarding uh
situations where you've got uh Crossing
local Authority borders uh for example
where a child's attending school uh
outside of Trafford but lives in
Trafford or vice versa um and what
awareness is there of additional
barriers uh that that puts in place
between uh different agencies and so on
um and what's being done to um overcome
those barriers so that those children
don't uh have a uh any individual uh
further disadvantage
disadvantages um and then finally it's
it's it is I think related to this
report to just ask a followup about the
question that we heard earlier uh about
s and attendance um if I could if I I
could indulge to ask a question uh about
is there a knowledge of individual
schools in Trafford who are coding sem
other than aai um uh absences other than
aai um and of the other
schools um how What proportion
approximately can we confidently say
they are definitely not coding absences
as
like
so I'll start the first one so yes you
are right we did go into the inspection
knowing that that was an issue um
because one we've got the data and two
parents and carers have been very clear
about some of that some of that
challenge um I think in terms of the
plans in place um there is there is a
numbers problem in the sense that the
resource
um dedicated to for example diagnosis
and the process of that and the numbers
that Trafford and everyone else in the
country are seeing there is a mismatch
there and so there there there is some
really difficult partner conversations
about what that's going to look like and
what that's going to mean um we've
started some of those but those those
need to continue because um there needs
to be
um a better response to that and
clarification for families about what
this will and will will not look like
both in the pre-diagnostic and
post-diagnostic support stage one of the
key drivers to that for me is better
understanding of the data so so where
what does that look like across ages
what does that look like across te of
needs what does that look like across
areas of Trafford are there other
factors for some children young people
in terms of um you know collocated need
etc etc what what does that mean so
um I that will continue to be an issue I
think that we will repeatedly come back
to here and in other places which I know
is
not I want to be really honest about
what that looks like and what that means
and you know is there an up to Steve
plan to get these numbers massively down
quickly no because it's a it's a
prolonged problem that's got that needs
some some system not just provider
Health provider and resource and
thinking um so that that that is the one
that that is going to cause I think the
most challenge to us it's also the one
that's going to cause parents and carers
and children um the most concern um and
I think we need to be honest about about
that and it will be something that no
doubt you will want us to keep coming
back to um and write and write so the
next one I'm not gonna ask just can I
just come in sh just on oh sorry then
Sally probably wants to to come in as
well in terms of the the M I think um
certainly what the inspection team
wanted from us was a commissioning
strategy um so that we're really clear
about what the needs analysis is telling
us and then obviously commissioning the
right level of service to to be able to
meet need um so I think that's that's
something that we are going to be
developing at fa at PACE and I think in
terms of neurodiversity and
andh um um I think the other thing that
they saw was that where there were so
where children and young people were
accessing and were able to access a
commissioned offer or support within
their schools around neurodiverse in MH
um actually needs were being met really
really well the challenge is we haven't
got it across all schools and settings
so there was an inequity as well so you
know there's a piece of work for us to
do around Workforce Development to
really because as as Shona said you know
unfortunately in terms of access to
specific Health Services it it's not
going to happen overnight and actually
we've got to do you're right that early
identification is really important
there's already work going on in the
early years around uh semh as well as as
neurodiversity particularly within the
early year sector
um but also what that Workforce
Development piece looks like um so that
that's another piece of work so that
schools and other partners are able to
to meet the needs of children and young
people sometimes without the need for a
diagnosis uh without the need for a plan
um but but just as as part of their
general practice Sally did you want to
come in on that I think you've said most
of what I was going to say Karen because
it was about I was just going to pick up
that they did recognize strength to the
training offer out there for schools
particularly but it was that it was
across the system it was the Workforce
Development making sure we all knew what
each other are doing so from the mental
health point of view from the speech and
language point of view from the the
senas offering training EPS you know it
was just it was about um that confidence
of parents in we know our school are
trained in this and it's you'll get the
same answer if you asked a health
colleague as if you asked an education
colleague that was really I think one of
the one of the things they
recognized I'm trying to think the other
question certainly the coding bit um was
there another one Sally before that um
there was crossborder issues wasn't
there want
to yeah I think um as far as it's
interesting because we were I was
chairing our panel this morning for ahc
decisions and we were discussing um a
few health reports and and um where
where children were under Manchester
Health Services for example and we were
making sure we were tasking our dco who
wasn't um who's actually on leave today
but we were tasking her with creating a
list of contacts for us of the local
area so the GM authorities and making
sure we know who to go to which we've
we've had before but you tend to get a
name of somebody but you know we were
asking for a Manchester pediatrician for
example then there might be somebody at
the RO Children's Hospital that we need
to hear from the speech and language
therapists tend to have um
um uh what's the right word um an
agreement basically across so they will
see children in each other's schools
don't insist that it's by the even
though they go by GP really they'll see
each other whereas other services will
say well if the resident in that you
know it goes with the GP generally for
most health so so there are some um
Sometimes some challenges but we're
certainly working hard to make sure that
we get that information whether it's
from the parent via the parent or
directly from those Health colleagues
we're also trying to build up a bit more
of a consistent approach to that so that
we know who to go to and where I don't
know if you had anything if it was
particularly around health or if if
you're if I'm answering the right bit of
the question or not I uh I mean what I
what I had in in mind more was
communication with uh working with um
for example schools outside the bur um
if data is being shared freely when
appropriate if there's Insurance on uh
compatibility formats the data is being
shared in that kind of
thing yeah I think um I think things I I
suppose as we've developed the data
systems in Trafford at the moment we've
improved very much our access with the
Eyes Part we've got an extra part of the
Liquid Logic system that we can have
live live attendance data from schools
but that is Trafford schools so the next
part of that is to make sure that we're
um you know we're getting the same
information from and there are one or
two of the of independent sector schools
that you can buy you can get into their
systems you know and share so we're on
in the process of trying to improve on
that particularly I think other
authority schools we usually receive
what we need um when when we're asked
for and again it comes back to those
annual reviews really and making sure
we've got all the right information for
the children with plans that is I think
as part of is it part of the IPA
agreement so when we do um place out
yeah for commission and independent on
our maintain setting we have an indiv
individual provision agreement where we
say what we expect from them what they
need to provide so if somebody's absent
for 10 days they need to be like us know
and discussing that and it says how much
we're funding and yeah so that's part of
the process as well for those
commissioned
places so I'll pick up briefly again the
coding in the particularly around um
emotionally based School non attendance
I think we're referring to there as part
of um trafford's attendance strategy
which is there to meet the requirements
of the working together to improve
School attendance we've rag R we we we
can QA so we do have sit of the school's
individual d we can see what they're
coding and that is quality assured by
the the team we've rag rated all of our
schools as well so uh any schools where
um absence or un unauthorized absence
persistent absence severe absence is
below National um they're receiving a
targeted support meeting visit at the
moment that was interesting when I met
with some of the heads on Friday they
weren particularly happy about the
volume of work they've got to produce
for these meetings um but they're going
ahead anyway uh and part of those
meetings is to absolutely get under the
skin of the individual cases uh looking
at the reasons for and then obviously
making sure that there's a wraparound of
of support and care for for those young
people who are struggling to
attend uh could I just ask a
clarification is does that answer the
question of if we're if the council's
aware of individual schools that are
coding mental health not as I if we are
not because I mean I'm sure I wasn't the
only one who was horrified at the
question there are
schools we have access to the schools
coding I mean without going into every
single individual case with every single
school um it you know I just don't know
whether we'd have the capacity to do
that um as I say we're working with this
we're targeting the well every school is
going to get a visit but we're rag
rating and we're working with the red
schools where we know attendance is of a
concern and we're going into definitely
those individual cases determine what
the causes are for the unauthorized
absence um so if that's any help but
obviously that's going to take all year
to actually hold those visits s it's
your team I don't know whether you want
to add anything I don't really I don't
think I've got anything else to car I
suppose just
yeah I too would be horrified if that
was going on in our schools because that
is not part of our attendance policy and
certainly not something that we um have
put in our attendance strategy and quite
likely
legal
okay thank you um councelor
Deacon my questions have been
sufficiently oh super um councelor
Duncan yeah thank you very much
um I'd just like to say again um thank
you for the report specifically to the
send team okay if it's clear you do a
lot of work that goes without saying
okay so thank
you um I have actually got the offset
put in front of me um and I've just
looked at the uh rooms for improvement
and quite rightly you do say that
there's a lot of jotting up here and
there and one thing and another so again
with that in mind children do clearly
need interaction and I'm still
fearful that we're
being pushed towards you know online
interaction and I I don't see that as
the way forward and I'm not here to
preach I'm here to just kind of voice an
opinion on what I've heard tonight
okay um and it goes back to the lady
with you know webinars and I I I must
kind of highlight to the committee
tonight that whilst parents or guardians
or carers would probably want that in
some cases for ease
I'm
sure that if there was actually told to
go to this meeting that you would
probably get more face-to-face
interaction now you will probably tell
me straight away that I am wrong but um
I'm I'm just fearful that we are being
held behind webinars and for six and
seven year olds that isn't the way
forward it's got to be face to face
surely
um yeah so again I thank you so much
because I know you've done a lot thank
you I think um just to say in terms of
the parent care engagement um most of
that is face Toof face um so um we're
about to do a PFA Workshop um and that
that will be face to face um because I
think that that is that that is what
pars and Care want and prefer I I think
the issues is about is about making sure
that there's a diverse range of
children's needs there's a diverse range
of experi expence and there's an element
of choice for children about what they
choose to interact with or not one of
the challenges that in the report is
making sure that there is Choice um and
we know that social opportunities
particularly for children would send are
um mixed so some good ones and there's
some that that are so good so for me
it's it's important that that level of
diversity is is is is there um
recognizing the differences and also the
accessibility issues that for some
children accessibility for digital is
really really positive dead strong but
for other children and young people and
for some families that that is not that
is not as um easy um and and also that
that that that need for for children
their C to have to have that option
really in terms of what that looks like
I think it's really important and we
will bear that in mind terms of the
strategy what's interesting about the
center world is most of our meetings we
have never face to face um Al our
Steering group our partnership board um
that they are all um they all face to
face uh when I came here I was told I
was just coming here two days a week and
now here four which is a bit of an
indication that we are we are doing
quite a lot of activity actually in
person I think just to say as well we
met with our special school heads it
last week and had a a long conversation
about Gathering the voice of the young
people because the heads and and the
practitioners there are probably the
experts in how to do that and we need to
to listen to them about how they would
Garner some of the voice of the child
and and and use use their expertise in
that so that was really insightful
actually and I know Sally going around
to every school I think to to to talk
about the voice of the child Outreach
support that they can provide to improve
our services across all of our schools
so some really exciting pieces of work
there I just say something about um
working with the children as well and
the young people just um think about the
the tutoring and things that we
commissioned so we've got sort of tutor
framework alterntive provision framework
and for quite a long time we we did
avoid having the online there's lots of
online tutoring offers
and we and and sometimes that worked
maybe for virtual school but from a S
point of view we didn't well all of us
to be honest didn't tend to go down that
route but I think some of that pressure
has come from parents in some and the
young people so in some situations you
know as as Sha said there's the
diversity some prefer it and it's a
starting point that you can then move to
face to face and then you might come out
of the house and then you might go to
school you know so it's really taking it
step by step but it also comes down to
who provides that so sometimes
the child might not want the school
doing it they want somebody different or
you know there's so many we tried to go
with their needs but we've got a range
on that framework but it is interesting
because there's a lot of online being
pushed out there commercially and we
have we've kind of picked carefully who
we think you know is is um best most
valuable and and sometimes you know
that's not necessarily money valuable it
might be the most costly but it's
because it's face to face or somebody's
willing to work in different settings
you know so we have providers who work
within the line library and then you
know it's just a step out of the house
for somebody so yeah just looking at
different ways all the
time okay councelor R thank you again
chair just a few more points on what
stood out from from the report firstly
on EHC plans uh it says in the report
that health professionals aren't always
receiving a copy of EHC plans that they
themselves have fed into basically
meaning that they can't cross check the
interpretation of their own professional
advice so I'd like to hear how and why
that's happening it's
seems pretty unacceptable really that
that's that's the case um transition to
adulthood has been mentioned a couple of
times already um it's it's patchy to say
the least I think the language in the
report doesn't match the strength of
feeling from send experienced families
out there it's patchy to say the least
and in some cases it would probably be
fairer to say non-existent not because I
say so but because that's what send
experience families want you to hear
tonight and that's what they've told me
to say so will we be reading much more
detail in February about the action
plans as how we move forward in terms of
transition to adulthood and the other
point that I just want to end on and
this is it for me um is educational
psychology has been pulled out in the
report and again tonight as an example
of a service which is performing really
well to read the report you'd think that
it's a service taking on fine without
any issues but I think again the report
is a little divorced from reality here
if you speak to Any teacher in our Bor
they will tell you that educational
psychologies chronically underresourced
it's difficult to get hold of and so
often children are not accessing those
services and that will be
that that won't be reflected in the
report we're reading tonight it's under
the surface masked and I'd like to hear
some thoughts addressing that as well
thank you
chair y so um Health seeing Draft plans
um it is an area for further development
to make sure it's happening on you know
for every every case I think it's the
timing really we need to shift back that
checking so that it wasn't it's not
happening at the draft plan because when
the draft plan goes out at that point
the family get to comment um if the
health colleagues were commenting at the
same time that wouldn't work so that the
health one needs to be earlier but it's
about the quality assurance really of
the health advice coming in so that it
doesn't need to be checked for every
case afterwards because they should know
what's going to be going in because
they've provided that advice and if
we're competing with different Health
advice perhaps from a private source and
an NHS Source then we need to resolve
that sooner so that is being works on
with our Health Partners we've got um
the our dco and our lead from the um
tlco um working really hard on that I
think there's there are gaps you know
and perhaps particularly cams I think we
we haven't worked with as closely as we
have with some of our therapy teams but
as far as checking what's in there that
needs to happen at the earlier stage so
the I think I think some health
colleagues were expecting it to be
shared at the draft point and get to
comment at that point and it's that's
not going to work for timeliness that
needs to happen much sooner so the dco
is on our on our panel so is the lead
pediatrician so they're in charge of
making sure that what's you know the the
advice coming in is uh the best quality
it can be and that people are
comfortable with how it's written in
there but then the the plans should be
shared with them it's just the amount of
feedback that's that's possible to make
at that later stage um needs to work for
the timeliness that help but yeah we
will keep reporting on any of that
through the ambition work as well
so in terms of the PFA um there there is
an awful lot of work that sit under
ambition for that's an ambition I forgot
to say that I'm leing on as well um so
um I I think um that the strength of
feeling amongst parents car is is very
much understood and heard um there are
multiple faceted issues in terms of
preparation for adulthood in terms of
timing accessibility to Services the way
that children's and adults health
services and services work really really
differently um so um there is parent
care representation on the group that
we're doing um I alluded to earlier that
um I'm running a PFA workshop for front
professionals and parents and carees
this not January February in February um
and but I
think I think it it we have to be really
clear about the Pro work in progress
there's not you know we're not going to
have a strategy and everything is going
to be resolved and we need to much
better understand the different layers
of preparation for agood so for example
um parents and care has said and ofstead
um concurred with our view that in the
complex pathway so for children who with
complex needs who are known to
Children's social care that pathway into
adulthood is is is is much improved and
and that is clearer um for young people
who don't who don't fit into those
categories that where that's not so um
linear if you like in terms of that that
level of need that is very very
different um and we know that that
that's something we've got to improve um
some of it is about access to
information as well how do I understand
what can be accessed how do I understand
what what that will look like what will
that mean so that families and children
young people are prepared in advance for
the way those things work so for example
in health services for children we work
in a Care Management type of model and
in adults um adults adult Health
Services work in episodes of care type
model it's a very different way to work
um but if parents and carers don't have
the information and they're not prepared
for that then they don't how how would
they know what that needs to do so more
than happy to come back with some more
detailed discussion around preparation P
to is something I spent a lot of my time
talking about but I think we have
to the February action plan will not say
and and now in trit all of it you know
it it has to be staged and we have to
align that with the information so that
actually we hear how that will improve
over time for parents and carers in
terms of translating some of the
intention into actually how that feels
differently some of it ties into the
annual review process the quality of
plans issues it's it's a jigsaw peace
freely so more than happy to come back
with that um and in terms of measuring
the progress but I think we have to
accept it will be steps in that in in
that in that um Progress way and we can
already see some evidence of that but at
the moment it screens shoots and it is
not across the board for All Families I
would totally accept that that that's
their experience and that's the
case thank you so a little bit around
the EP service um certainly and and
you've referred to teachers making the
comments as well I'm assuming that's
access to EPS to carry yet
um and there were certainly were issues
the EP service um probably last year not
this year did go through a staffing
churn we had fee maternity leaves um we
had changes in Staffing um and
recruitment to EPS is not easy so the
certainly our principal EP brought in
Associates to cover off some of the
certainly the staty work that needed to
be completed um and that did that did
cause instability across the service
it's an SLA service so it's it's not all
Council funded so it it is paid for by
the slas that are purchased by the
schools and it's actually one of the
strongest slas that we do have in
Trafford it is a highly regarded um
service some of our schools who are in
big trusts they opt out and they're
using the EPS that provided by the
education trusts so certainly people in
the bat trust right Futures trust will
um buy in their own EPs and I know there
have been issues even within the trust
to actually provide that that level of
support I think the other bit that the
EPS would say is the number of requests
for needs assessments um has driven up
the statutary work and actually their
work should really be around
preventative work and Workforce
Development they are such incredibly
passionate people who who are able to
just deliver some wonderful pieces of
work in school but getting to be able to
do that when they're having to do the
statutary work it's been really complex
for them the team are up to capacity now
and um but as I say it's just balancing
out the need that we know to to do the
statutary work again some of the the
workforce work is continues to be be a
challenge but at the moment we obviously
don't have any extra funding to to
develop any further capacity within the
service um okay I've got counselor Hurst
and then counselor
Hy hi um we you talked at the beginning
about not knowing um where the
weaknesses were in in the a report and
there particular issue say with
transitions the voice of the child and
about time scales for say new Divergence
and I know particularly the time scales
for autism and ADHD assessment have
increased a lot recently particularly
since covid but I mean I I sat on the
corporate parenting board perhaps six or
seven years ago and the issues of
transition and voice of the child were
the same men as they are now and I'm
concerned that you know saying that we
know that there's a problem isn't the
solution and there's been drift and I
don't know whether it's because the
strategies you've tried to address that
haven't been successful or whether it's
been allowed to drift but what I'd like
to know that it isn't going to drift
anymore and I know you said it can't be
changed instantly I totally get that
these are big things but have we got any
time scales timelines or or plans that
will bring parents Faith back into the
system I mean certainly in terms of
drift management grip all of those sorts
of things um you know we we have worked
hard certainly of late to really address
that and I think we've been really clear
that we needed to strengthen those
governance Arrangements um and the
management grip and we've not shied away
from that and you know some of that was
probably the hardest thing for us to
swallow actually um but we have worked
really hard to make sure that we have
that now um to make sure that we've got
proper strategic representation at the
Strategic board where we've got the
movers and shakers if you like that can
really challenge but also influence um
the Strategic board now reports up to
the locality board um because you know
those whole ICB Arrangements again we'
we've really got to shift thinking and
commitment there as well and and hearts
and mind stuff actually around the Sun
System um I think the fact that you know
we we broke it in an independent chair
who br brings with her a wealth of
expertise she's worked with local
authorities in um pretty poor and
financial positions as well as well as
written statements of action etc etc so
brings a wealth of expertise and she
doesn't shy away from challenge that's
for sure um so we've we've really worked
hard to strengthen that and and as as
shoner has talked about all the
performance performance information the
quality insurance that sits behind that
you know that is that is something that
that's been a real priority um so
with those arrangements and I think
ostad shared this they were confident
that we had the mechanisms now in place
the grip the challenge uh to ensure that
we bring around rapid Improvement but
I'll I'll kind of move on to sh around
PFA Etc so I think some of that is why
why why I'm here so um you know the the
sense system like lots of systems is
very stretch I don't have any
operational responsibilities I'm not
making decisions about about about
children so that that means that some of
my time and some of the the activity
that that I can do is is much more um
Hands-On in terms of um re um developing
some of that resource so I think some of
trafford's commitment to that is by the
fact that they have sourced me to do it
and asked me to keep doing it I was
supposed to be here for six months still
here six months and a few weeks later um
so I I think some of that is and some of
some of my um remit really is about
place and traction some of it is about
right we've been talking about some of
this stuff for a while how do we start
to see that move I think also some of it
is about how we measure the pace of
improvement so instead of keep saying
well we're doing this and we're doing
that well what can we say how can we say
it um so in the inspection I use the
analogy of jam tomorrow versus green
shoots so actually are we just talking
about it or can we say some of those
tangible things and I think in terms of
the Improvement plan itself and what we
publish we will need to be very very
clear well if I'm a parent and career
what am I what am I going to say how is
this going to look different how do we
how do we um measure ourselves really
about are the things that we think going
to work do they work
are they the right things to do or
actually do we need to do something else
so I think that that kind of ongoing
measure of how we do that which is why
we've been really clear that the improve
the Ambitions plan needs to have metrics
so that we canot just talk about send
which we all can do quite a lot but
actually how do we know that this is
making any difference and with what sort
of numbers um because otherwise it
becomes about the conversation that
someone had yesterday the school they
were in yesterday that you know that
without any really hard you know there
are nearly 3,000 children trafficed with
hcp plans that that's that's a lot of
young people so we really need to be
really clear about about how we do that
and certainly that that's part of the
think the um the quite Wily the
commitment that we need to make in terms
of the the published plan and and
obviously we need to use our governance
so that people can say you know and
through the um scr process that that
Kina was part of through this well
actually is that doing what what you
said and and I think that governance
part is is very very very important k
did you want to come in on this at all
um yeah basically I was going to say I
don't think we've had a question tonight
that I haven't asked these women over
the last few weeks and um you know
including yesterday when we're writing
the plan and I'm going well you know
what is this accommodation strategy that
you talk about I think what I really
wanted to say and I I agree with Emma
you know I sat on that corporate
parenting board eight years ago and we
did talk about transition to adulthood
we did talk about EHC people and um and
I I I absolutely agree with sha that I
think we're beginning to see um um some
movement in that some of that has been
to do that we got inadequate in
children's services so I think our Focus
sort of moved away from
send um and I think really why I can of
indicated to Denise I wanted to speak
was um you get told you're going to have
an inspection and we kind of prepared as
much as we could for an inspection but
when it came I think it was possibly the
most intense three weeks um I can
remember it felt like the world stopped
for three weeks because he ins spect us
are in and um and and the whole process
has happened quite quickly you know we
had the
feedback um in November was it and then
they didn't publish the report till
December and then they want a response
by February
um
so really I I I want to speak to pay
tribute to these three women and the
teams that they lead and all of the
people underneath them but you know the
amount of work and understanding I think
we all understand that the number of
children young people with special needs
is rising exponentially in Trafford that
you know we've the number of children on
lands has gone up nearly 20% in the last
two years so we have got a crisis and
you know it feels like we're in the
middle of this at the moment and we're
having to work out but
really it is absolutely right that we we
challenge every opportunity to make sure
we get the best for traffic children but
I also want to say a massive big thank
you as well for what they've done and
how we've got this far and I think we
all acknowledge we're we're not at the
beginning of the journey but we're
nowhere near the end either um you know
and I'm I've been actually really
thrilled at how much interest elected
members have shown you know because it
just shows that you all care as much as
we all
care thank you thanks Karina
counselor thanks I wanted to Echo Echo
what Karina's just said um I noticed
that you referenced earlier that you
were fully staffed um and do you think
that part of the ISS or you were up to
full numbers and you couldn't take
anymore do you think part of the issues
that we had were perhaps because you
were underst staffed and as Karina said
if there's an increase of 20% and that
continues with the kind of bedroom
children I think is is the phrase having
these sorts of
issues do you do you think we could end
up sliding backwards again I think in
terms of of I mean that was the ep the
Ed educational s psychology service we'd
always love to have more more people
more EHC coordinators more send advisory
service staff more health staff um but
but it's just it's just not realistic so
we're you know we're aware that we have
to work within our means um I suppose
everything that we are trying to do is
to as Shona said it's it's a local area
approach isn't just the local Authority
and and schools themselves have to see
themselves as part the solution as well
we have to come together and do things
differently within within the means that
that we've got to work uh and within the
financial envelope that we've got to
work and and the most important thing I
think for us is to make sure we can get
trust and confidence back into the
system back into into send in Trafford
and and that's you know that's certainly
what we're trying to do through the work
of the Ambitions plan and through all
the engagement work that we're going to
do with Partners um I would absolutely
you know it we will not slip backwards
because our governance Arrangements
won't allow us to slip back um we're
going to have meetings regularly with
DFE I think it's every six months you
know it's it it just can't happen we'll
be reinspected in three years time but I
think you know as shown has said it's
going to take time just because we we
haven't got a money tree we haven't got
people coming out for ear but but there
is commitment and passion to do the
right
thing did I just come in as well I was
just going to say um something that the
inspection really shown a light on for
me as well though was that how you know
we talk about sending everybody's
business and certainly in water side it
certainly was was not just because the
inspection but all the teams you know
everybody is talking about send I'm
think all the team Sarah managers around
you know attendance transport admissions
everybody has got a part to play and I
think that looking at the data
everybody's playing their part and
looking at send within their teams
rather than it just being well send
staff for doing that you know so I think
that we haven't got more staff but we
are sharing the the load I think across
all teams now which feels better and I
think you know the same with with health
colleagues as well so and social care
thanks thank you thank you very much
just before we move on from send um at
the end of the last meeting um we had an
update regarding um s
tribunals um and I think there's
definitely an appetite you can see the
um the number of questions and the
amount of Interest
um another thing that's come up tonight
is transition to adulthood as well or
transitions in general but I'm just
thinking as a committee um is there an
agreement amongst committee members I
have to do this formally by the way so
um that they would be interest in task
and finish in one or both of those areas
in particular yeah okay so I think can
we set something in motion we we need to
scope it out for the reason but I I know
I understand I have dealings with
Trafford parent Forum myself and I know
how Keen um people are to for us to look
at these so we will hold you to account
but as you know um but thank you so much
for the report um and to see the
Improvement I'd actually printed off the
previous um report as well and we have
come on in Leaps and Bounds so thank you
to all your teams for all the hard
work okay thank thank you you're welcome
to stay ladies for um the the next item
which will be the final item which is on
um School Place planning and sufficiency
I'm sure that's going to be you Karen I
know I bring this one every year Well no
I think I've got a very very capable and
ex expert member staff next to me Sarah
you know um so basically you've had the
report um Sarah Butters who obviously
leads on everything around sufficiency
planning uh will will walk us through
the report and then we'll take questions
at the end thank
you thanks Karen um so the report
outlines our approach to school Place
planning which includes the statutary
annual return to the department for
Education which is called the scap
survey um and I think there's quite a
lot of detail there around what that
methodology looks like and the processes
that we go through um we very much work
in partnership with colleagues across
States and planning around new housing
developments and making sure that
the pupil yields expected from those new
developments are built into the pupil
Place planning formula and approach um
we have secured a significant amount of
Education contributions through section
106 agreements um in some areas where
we've got very large um levels of new
development and that contributes to the
basic need money that we received from
the Department for education to create
additional places um we did receive an
allocation of
19.77% for financial year
2526 and there is a really detailed
report around the projects that are
planned um with that allocation that's
going to trafford's Executive in January
so I don't know if people are aware of
that but there is more detail in a
separate
report um the pupil forecasting um
Remains the accuracy of the pupil
forecasting remains strong um on the
latest EF scorecard the forecasts for
within one year were bang on and then
for within two years with we're within
0.4% the D has a tolerance level of 2%
so in terms of the accuracy of the
forecast that's working well um in entry
to reception in 2023 94% of applicants
were offered their first preference
school so that's children starting in
reception year um what we've got in
traid is we've got this kind of
difficult problem if I can just point
out the table in
3.9 um we've got Surplus places in all
areas for into reception year but then
we have pressures in Upper year groups
particularly in the ALR and sale area um
so we've got this issue where the birth
rate in traford is decreasing and we
know we've had the lowest birth rate in
a de in a decade when the numbers were
released for 2022 so we we are going to
need less Prim R places in the future in
some areas in other you know in
different areas that's offset by the
migration rate into Trafford before
children are sort of hit age four and
then that kind of ongoing pressure that
we have from iny applications where
people move in partway through their
education so you will be aware we have
significant pressures in school years
2021 2122 where we had real real big
spikes in inye applications um and we
are still seeing the inye application
rates in primary around 37% higher than
the pre-pandemic level although they
have dropped from the Sur years that
we've
had um in the report you'll see there's
really detailed tables for each of the
the planning areas which shows the
number of places in each area by year
group the number unroll in each area and
the percentage of vacancies and it also
shows you by a group where we have
places allocated over the published
admission numbers in
schools so I won't go through that in
detail um when we move on and think
about sufficiency for secondary which
has been one of the biggest pressures
for us particularly in the Central and
South neighborhoods um in entry to year
7 in secondary in 2023 75% of applicants
were offered the first preference and
that's significantly lower than the
national rate of 82% and that's really
reflective of um the pressures that
we've seen on places and also our
selective system impacts on
that
um thinking around the entry to
secondary in 2024 I just want to
highlight that because that has been um
a big pressure for us um so part of our
strategy over the last couple of years
around it's been around tailored advice
to families making sure that they apply
for all their local non-selective
schools so that we can sort of protect
as many places as possible for Trafford
resident parents um and try and allocate
places in local areas to people um and
that has actually been largely
successful um it's a positive position
that we've received 147 less
applications this time round than we had
last time round that's reduced the
pressure a little um and we've also the
early indication figures are showing
we've got 33 residents in ringham and
sale who will not be be able to be
offered a place in their local area and
that's down quite significantly we had
92 in that position the year before so
there are some improvements um I think
there's you know we're still in the
process of creating additional places in
the secondary sector at alrm
College um I'd just like to also
highlight it's not in the report but I
just wanted to give a bit of an update
on the number of places in our selective
schools that are accessed by non-
Trafford resident pups um so in 2023 we
had a total of 363 out of borrow pupils
in our grammar schools so that's just in
year seven um and that is actually been
a small increase on the year before so
it's a 1 percentage Point increase from
28% to
29% um and when we kind of look at that
broken down by areas there's been an
increase in the number of pupils from
out of buret in in them in sale areas
but there has actually been a decrease
in the stretford and Herston areas for
the grammas where they're attracting the
out of Bor pupils and so the overall
increase was 25 extra out of Bor pupils
in 23 compared to
2022 um when we look at the non
selective schools we've got 94 out of
Bor pupils in our non-selective schools
across the whole of Trafford um so
generally speaking that's children that
will be a high priority within the
admissions criteria so looked after
previously looked after children um
maybe siblings um but that number is
really quite small it remains at 4% um
so we are confident that with the
strategies that we've put in place we're
protecting as many places as possible in
the nonselective schools for Trafford
residents so I guess in total that's 457
out of Bor pupils that we have in in
year seven in Trafford um it's important
to remember as well that some of our
Trafford residents choose to access a
place outside of Trafford so the export
figure is 211 so we've got 21 Trafford
residents choosing to access schools in
Manchester sford chesher and other areas
there are a range of reasons behind
those placements sometimes it's just
geographical proximity sometimes it's
for religious reasons or for a
particular type of
school um should we I think that's it
probably in terms of summary of the
reports if we want to open to questions
okay well you've answered my question
already which Karen knew was coming
obviously um how many out of borrow
children are taking places in our
schools but um yeah that's my annual
question um Council Duncan you question
thank you
Jeff
just all right brilliant okay thank you
again um It's really
informative um how do you prioritize
School placements
please so the biggest factor in pupil
placement is Parental preference so each
of our schools to start with would Al
would have an over subscription criteria
and that's for the admission authority
of the school to set and then they
that's how places are prioritized linked
to the over subscription criteria in
terms of where a an offer can be made
it's very much linked to parental
preference and what they put on that
application form so there will always be
it's a blind preference system there'll
always be offered the highest possible
preference that we can when we look at
all applications collectively linked to
the over subscription criteria so there
are in you know there are certain groups
of children who will always be
prioritized in every school's admission
um policy such as looked after children
previously looked after children
siblings I think just to to U come in on
that as well um certainly when we look
at Place planning and when we look at
some of the sufficiency planning so if
we're if we're needing to create
additional places Etc you know there's a
whole pile of data that that Sarah and
the team have access to um because that
it's that data that generates the
funding then that allows us to expand
schools um and hence you know the the
development of altering room College
because we knew there were go there were
going to be pressures there and also
thinking about the housing developments
and the impact and where we can we can
scope expansions of our schools um in in
the right areas so you know Sarah
there's a whole pile of of dates that
you have access to to inform that
sufficiency
planning okay thank you Sarah thank you
thank you um councelor
Deacon thank you and thank you for the
report um mine was just a question on
the uh section 106 agreements funded um
in terms of those figures are they the
financial year to date just and then or
could you explain the discrepancy
between um primary the amount taken for
primary and the amount secondary there
quite a big difference given what you
noticed in terms of the pressure on
Secondary School places I'd be
interested to to hear more yeah so it's
not in a particular Financial year it's
a kind of um cumulative total since
we've been securing contributions
through the current
methodology um and I think it's really
important to note that these are not
receipts these are secured in agreements
but for receipt at a future point in
time um so any expansions that we do do
are forward funded by basic need and
then contributed to at a later Point
once these are received um the reason
there's such a big difference has just
been around the methodology which is
deployed to do the calculation and it's
linked to Surplus number of secondary
places in particular areas so we've got
got three secondary schools in Trafford
which are undersubscribed one in
Partington one in stretford one in
flixon um and a big significant portion
of the development works that we've seen
have been in stretford for example where
we've got a consistently got a surplus
number of places and therefore it
doesn't generate a contribution through
the section 106 um so that's the kind of
discrepancy really I think when we've
done the calculations for different
housing developments and sale and
altering them um we still have to factor
in that people can travel to access a
place and we might have service places
elsewhere thank you Council
pro thank you chair okay fles off
again one's just a why question and then
once
um a bit there got a bit more to it um
on
1.4 um a key strategic priority is to
remove vertically grouped classes I was
just wondering why because there are
such
benefits to Children of different
abilities being in a vertically grouped
class so that's that one and then the
other
one is about
the here we go so when Trafford Waters
got through planing permission from
memory there was a commitment to build a
school in Trafford Waters because of
this massive size of the
development that makes me
question why um we're keeping as a
future option to expand um DAV H primary
when the
overwhelming um result of the
consultation was
that people around dve primary didn't
want it to be expanded and so when
Trafford Waters build a primary school
surely there wouldn't be need wouldn't
be a need for places to be expanded in D
primary thank you some great questions
there um in in terms of the the mixed AG
classes the vertically grouped group
classes um sometimes the funding
Arrangements that so that inform a
school budget particularly with with
some of those pans can be quite complex
um and uh so sometimes s that isn't
always the best option in terms of
Staffing a school and just just making
the the budget Stack Up um some schools
as well would are and this is somebody
who has taught vertically groups and has
led a school with vertically groups and
the organizational side of the
curriculum is really quite challenging
um in in in terms of having uh mixed age
classes um and uh you know I think
sometimes heads would argue that that
that actually becomes a challenge I
accept that mixing up different year
groups is a is a really lovely
opportunity for for children to to
interact with others um sometimes that
can become quite complex uh in terms of
meeting needs also parents can also have
interesting views about which class
their child should be in etc etc so from
an operational uh position I think it's
not always been most helpful for some of
our schools um and so I think that's
something that we've we've always tried
to to work to to getting a 1 Fe or
preferably a 2 Fe um School in place in
terms of the DAV H bits I mean Sarah
there is a bit more we've been debating
the water Trafford Waters bit haven't we
yeah um and I think the planning
permission for the school at Trafford
Waters was granted nine years ago now
and obviously I think Trafford has um
you know there's been so many changes in
terms of people place planning what our
projections look like the demographic so
it's a very historical decision that
that would be the best solution and it
is something that's still still being
worked through um I think in the
original planning permission it was for
I think there was expected to be a
single form of Entry primary school and
we know the DFE don't open single form
of Entry primary schools anymore because
of the financial challenges um and that
not being sustainable um I think when we
consider as well in some of the
surrounding areas in the schools when we
consider the falling birth rate and the
the droing numbers coming through in
some of the primary schools maybe not
just in the erston area but also where
it borders stford we've got to think
really strategically before we make any
decision I guess of the best way to meet
the solution uh for Trafford Waters so
that's all going VI of work thank you I
think linked to the day beh Hume I mean
certainly at the time because I think
one of the other things one of the other
factors when we look at expansions of
schools making sure it's in the right
area is really important but we also
have to carry out feasibility studies to
check which schools are in scope to
actually be expanded and the stock is
becoming much more complex now to
actually fit expansions on um and and so
that kind of factored into some of the
decision making we took around Davey
Hume at the time but it is you know it
is only an option and not something that
we would necessarily progress unless we
really really have to thank you
councelor
s um yeah thanks uh looking at the alham
area um the uh publish the exceeding
publish adition number is right across
key stage two um with Willow's primary
key stage two places open um the broom
primary uh use of an intervention space
is due to come to an end at the end of
this school year um is that confirmed
that that will be the case and so will
that school regain its intervention
space bear in mind increasing hcps and
so on Intervention defention spaces are
absolutely vital uh or is it possible
that that school is going to be uh um
asked to keep that space in use as a
classroom longer term and will that be
detrimental to the
school um so I can confirm that we
achieved the additional classroom in the
short term through conversion of an
intervention space but that space was
rovided through a small Capital scheme
so the school has not overall lost its
intervention space um each year in the
spring term the school places board
reviews the INE applications position
and the current occupancy across the
whole you know of all of our schools in
all areas and we make decisions about
whether we need to continue with um
temporary creation of of capacity or
whether it would stop so that's normally
a decision that's made by the end of
March and then that'll be communicated
with the
school that's help clarification
intervention thanks thank you councelor
Andis thank you chair coun s Nick my
question um definitely well I've got two
anyway
um yeah thank you for the report and
specifically welcome the measures that
have been taken in the altering and
primary planning area especially
Willow's expansion and as well what's
been done temporarily uh in in brinwood
just on the uh sufficiency of secondary
school places though uh you said right
at the start back in relation to the
public question um that there was no
datab basis for uh a new a new Secondary
School in the erston area could you just
talk a bit about the the is there more
of a database in the south of the b in
the ringham area and obviously
mentioning the traffic Waters
development before and perhaps the
contingency for a new school there it
does seem with the proposed building
works that we're looking at the council
is looking at for uh South Trafford that
that if that's the case in in traffic
Waters why would it not be the case in
in aling just seem to follow
logic we
have I just make sure I get this right
so we have fully explored the option for
cre creating a new school in the South
new secondary school and we don't have
an an Evidence shortfall of demand that
meets the minimum requirements for a new
school that was fully explored with the
DFE but doesn't apply it is that is that
what you're asking sorry if I miss yeah
it just seems interesting with if
there's talk of a new school and and
perhaps rightly so in of waters
development why not in in terms of what
we're looking at for for development in
the sou
B I think some of it is around I mean we
you know in terms of the pupil yield um
I think the basis for a small the
smallest Secondary School would need a
um I think it's 750 a demand of 750
pupils to actually create the smallest
uh of secondary schools um and and
certainly at the time when we when we
worked with the DFE around this um it it
was just determined that we we just
weren't in that position um we'd also
obviously have to go down the um I think
it's the presumption free school route
if I've got that right um which would be
uh you know receive funding from DFE
because we don't have the funding you
looking at probably um I don't know um
about 25 million pounds to set up a a
small special school we don't have that
in the in in in the basic need funding
so we did go down that route hence then
the expansion at Ultron College to meet
the additional demand um and you know we
are continuing to look at what the
feasibility is looking like in the of
the south of the bough um we did a
feasibility study at North cestrian that
was a couple of years ago I think the
other thing that we have to look at is
what gives us best value for money
because we can create an expansion at
North krian but if it's only creating
you know a few places at a high cost and
we can get better value somewhere else
we we've got to work within the
financial envelope that we've got as
well don't know Sarah is there anything
you want to add around that sure we've
answered the question properly then can
I address that as well um it there was a
lot of Lobby when when Karen says we
asked the DF it that wasn't a oneoff can
we have one and they said no I mean it
was it was a um quite a Relentless
campaign really and you know I I've been
very um Pro not proactive but um very
positive that if we built a school they
would come I say this Karen all the time
part of the problem is where would we
put it but also the other problem um
really is that there are that whilst
there are some children that don't get
spaces there's not enough children that
don't get spaces and um so I think I'm
looking at Sarah here Mike Kane MP was
involved in this um s Gran Brady was
definitely involved in this you know and
once we' kind of brought out our big
guns and you know we were still told no
so it's a sadness um we are getting more
places altering them and and we are back
in discussions with nor cestrian and I'd
just like to recommend What Sarah Said
at the beginning if you're interested in
school places there's um a much more
detailed report coming to execo Monday
and in that it lists all the building
work we have done over the last 10 years
and what's still in the pipeline um and
it's incredible really I think we've
created nearly 5,000 School places since
2010 is that right oh is going to say
actually Karina it's
4,797
um you are right
4,646 places it is is a good good
estimate you know so sometimes I get
really annoyed that we're we we do get
accusations that we don't care about
South and you know people haven't got
places we've done an enormous amount of
work to make sure that children can be
educated in the B of choice we were
impacted with um the amount of um Hong
Kong residents who we welcome into the
burough um but that caused a problem
with places not a problem with them
being here um a problem with um finding
extra places and as Sarah pointed out
lots of people are moving into the
burough year four year five to give them
a better chance for grammar schools and
that will always be the case in a select
of
bur thank you um councilor Paul did you
have a last
question hi uh thank you for the report
it's there's a lot of Statistics in
there so um I hope I'm not repeating
anybody else's question here um so
relating to uh the new housing
development in Carrington uh this new
carington and Temple wedge uh so there
is going to be a huge demand like there
would would be around more than 5,000
households if I'm not mistaken so
obviously there'll be lots of kids who
would want School places and um so would
you have statistics on where these kids
uh would get the school places and
already kids from sale are traveling to
schools in Partington and loar and
parents have been complaining to us
about there in their emails so um and
and I I do appreciate that you would be
getting additional places allocated in
the existing schools but would you still
think that they would be sufficient
enough and there would be enough
capacity to actually accommodate all
these kids in those schools would you
have any kind of Statistics in in that
regard thank
you yeah so I'll just think about those
two developments separately so with
regards to new Carrington um we've very
much done a full and detailed analysis
of all the um housing developments which
are planned and part of our strategic
plan is to expand broo to create the
secondary places to meet that demand um
and there are some details in here
around the expected number of pupils
that we expect to come into the
secondary sector there and thinking
about the primary sector around the
Partington area we've got three primary
schools there and we know there is
appetite amongst the trust and the dasis
there for expanding those schools when
that is required to meet that additional
demand but we are for some of these
things talking maybe 10 or 15 years
further down the line so it's longer
term plans um we do have a surplus at
the moment of places in The primary
sector in Partington so that will be
utilized first and then we will consider
the expansions but our calculations
indicate we can achieve all the
additional places needed by expanding
what's already there um thinking about
the simply wedge allocation um we've got
the biggest decline in birth rate in the
altering and planning area we've got the
highest rate of vacancies in the lower
year groups there because of that and we
think you know anecdotally that people
have been priced out of of living in in
this area um so the detailed
calculations for the timly wedge are
indicating that we will be able to
utilize the projected surpluses in some
of these schools um to protect the
financial sort
of viability of those of those schools
moving forwards I think the Assurance we
can provide is that it's really detailed
calculations around the expected pupil
yields from each of those strategic land
allocations thank you thank you thank
you very much for the report and thank
you to members for the questions um and
I'm not aware of any urgent business um
so with that thank you for coming and
wish you all a good night and a safe
journey home thank
you